[موسيقى]
كان شعور يوم ما ختمت القران شعورا لا
يوصف
فرحت كثيرا
وكان تزامنا مع ذهاب جدتي الى العمره
فحقيقه كانت الفرحه فرحتين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رمضان الذي انزل فيه القران هدى للناس
وبينات من الهدى والف
رقان
[موسيقى]
خاصمت كتاب الله في سنه 2019
تزامنا مع حصول على شهاده على شهاده
في الادب العربي اخترت تخصصي الادب العربي
لاني مولعه باللغه
ومعرفه تفاسير او التفاسيرها وتفاسير
القرانيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فلا تنسى الا ما شاء الله
[تصفيق]
كانت الفتره الاولى مده الاسبوع الاول او
الثاني كانت نوعا ما صعبه
يعني مش
ليست صعبه بدرجه بدرجه كبيره ولكن كان
تاقلمي انا كاول مره لا لم يكن جيدا ولكن
الحمد لله
لقد
تعودت عليهم وتعودنا علي
وعلاقتي بهم حقيقه
علاقه طيبه احببتها احببتم كثيرا
الا الا
ما انه يعلم الجهر وما
يقبل فذكر انك
تج